i have with me
david pakman he is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but the whole
whoa whoa jesse well we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot of agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman
he is
that is a jam but let's get right to it
um the schedule today has been
just completely thrown into the trash
donald trump is supposed to be speaking
in 15 minutes
in reading or reading pennsylvania i
don't know how it's pronounced
that was rescheduled to a half hour from
now but he will never make it
because he's still speaking right now in
newton pennsylvania
we're going to have clips of this at the
same time
joe biden and barack obama scheduled to
be speaking momentarily so we're
monitoring that
also kamala harris scheduled to be
speaking in about 40 minutes
in fort lauderdale i can't find a stream
of it
i can't find any event on youtube that
seems to have that as a scheduled event
my goal was to kind of see what
everybody's doing we are in the last
three days of the campaign
so i guess if anybody knows where the
kamala stream is
let me know how to find it let me know
which channel is carrying it i very much
want to see what barack obama has to say
in flint michigan momentarily and then
i'm not even gonna go to this trump
thing i mean let's just listen to a few
seconds he was supposed to be done
here an hour ago you know it's just a
mess of a schedule
ilhan omar will be running homeland
security
how do you like that who knows i just
said that one but you know what
i wouldn't so this is very very stupid
and again i was my thought was
um that we would cover the second trump
speech which again the second one is
supposed to be 15 minutes from now
rescheduled for 30 and he will never
ever ever ever
ever make it so let's stay here just for
now
let me know when biden obama go live and
we will get i will switch over
um and in fact actually can i even leave
the art let's see
oh my god we can't even hear this this
is no doubt
the most important election we can't
hear a word of it so it doesn't even
matter right now
okay let me know when that happens and
then if someone also
knows if there's a kamala stream for a
little bit while from now
let me know about that i'm trying to
keep the schedules are in the trash we
don't know who's doing what trump's an
hour late let's actually look at trump's
schedule
so this is in newton pennsylvania and
that was supposed to be
ending at one it's now two trump's still
talking
and then trump was supposed to arrive at
the next location
40 minutes ago uh by plane
and then 10 minutes after that get to
reading pennsylvania
where he was supposed to arrive in five
minutes and speak
in 15. uh you know it's just
who the hell knows what is going on um
but the schedule is is absolutely
ridiculous
um okay oh by the way i do have a clip
so
this people were sending this to me and
saying it sounds like trump
is almost doing a concession speech this
is earlier in this same event let's
listen to it
here we go i'm to do that sleepy joe
biden
it could have been the greatest you know
if you look
uh we look at the amount of money that
he
has raised hundreds of millions 300
million dollars one month
but i could have been the greatest of
all time i could have been the greatest
political fundraiser i tell him to do
that's sleepy okay yeah
sounding sounding very depressed and
down not quite a concession speech but
he does sound relatively defeated there
i also do plan i see people in the
twitch chat saying i should also be
looking at the
polls i will be doing that and i hope to
have time today to do my my map my
270 to win map at least based on the
numbers today
and of course the numbers may change the
numbers may well change
also i don't know if you guys heard but
there were uh
there was vehicular intimidation and
even side swiping
a bunch of trump flag laden vehicles
surrounding the biden
bus i guess in texas and there was
actually
some wait where where did i have that
here there was actually some
side swiping that took place i mean it's
vi it's violence
it's violence is what it is it's it's
completely stunning that this is going
on
uh this is this is criminality these are
hit and runs
uh hit hit and hits it's really hits and
run
what's the plural of that it's like
attorneys general
um but in any case we're going to be
literally terrorists exactly right we
are going to be talking about that
big thanks to chris goodings by the way
who signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com i do want to say thanks
to chris
who's new member number one today few
super chats going on
uh dr chakaseki radiologist at large
said honking horn guy at the biden rally
yesterday probably represents the sounds
going on inside blotus's head
the clown car of the republican party
drives onwards yes very much so
also via super chat deepak what's the
number for the based
department i have no idea i have no idea
and then via twitch andre bavaria says
hey david how will you be covering
election day best wishes from bavaria
i'm just going to go live about 7 p.m
eastern and you know it's funny
i get a whole bunch of people who are
wanting to know what my plan is for
election day so they can watch
and then i've got a whole bunch of
people saying david don't even bother
streaming on election day
because hassan will be live and he's
going to take all your twitch audience
and kyle kolinsky's going to be with joe
rogan and he's going to take all of your
youtube audience you're not gonna have
anybody watching
oh okay i guess i'll just sit at home
and stare at the wall
uh no i'll be live i will be live and i
think we will have
i think it'll be a fine stream and we'll
see how well it does it doesn't have to
be
the best stream but i think we will have
interest and what i can tell you for
sure is
last election we had 1500 live viewers
on election night
i will bet any amount of money we have
more than 1500 live viewers
um and oh and people asking about a
subscriber target
so my as many of you know i had a goal
of
1 million subscribers by election day we
got there
a month and a half ago so my goal by
election day is 1.1 million
youtube subscribers we're at 1.07 so i
think it's it's going to be tight i mean
30
000 subscribers in three days it's it's
it's
hard to expect hard to expect that but
um that's the goal and oh wait no that's
not 30 000
i'm sorry that's 3 000 right
no it is 30 okay i'm having some math
problems that is 30 okay so maybe that
that's not going to be possible but the
goal
i guess my goal is to get 30 000 new
youtube subscribers between now and uh
now and tuesday okay people are sending
me links to the kamala stream
but links are not allowed in the chat so
let's see
ah there it is there it is okay so we've
got the kamala stream
oh barack obama let's listen
you got the michigan michigan state game
and that's a big deal low audio do we
have better audio anybody let me find a
better stream
but this tuesday
here we go on the line whether or not we
get this pandemic under control
is on the line but here's the good news
on tuesday you can choose change
yes on tuesday you can elect joe biden
and kamala harris you can choose a
better
america and what's even better news is
you don't have to wait until tuesday to
cast your ballot michigan
you can vote in person right now
just go to iwillvote.com find your
polling place
get out there and vote
and if if somebody like you already
voted
go help your friends and family make a
plan to vote
right because we need everybody not just
some people
we go we got to get everybody out there
i love you too okay that's it
put that mask back on
listen michigan
joel biden is my brother i love this i i
love
joe biden and he will be a great
president
now i'll admit 12 years ago when i
when i asked him to be the nominee
for vice president was with me when i
was oh my god the audio
that well we had served together in the
senate i'll look for another stream
he and i came from different places
part of different generations but i
quickly came to admire joe as a man
who learned early on to treat everybody
he meets with dignity
and with respect living by the words
his mom taught him no one's better than
you joe let me just see here if i've got
better audio
you're no better than anybody else i do
okay i'm just gonna switch streams for
you guys i always want to bring you the
best audio
and some of the audio is a little bit
toxic um
but i think we've got uh better audio
right here this will be a better stream
i think
always the best for you the belief that
everybody counts
there's no joe is
and that's who he'll be as president i i
can tell you
the presidency doesn't change who you
are it shows who you are
it reveals who you are
and for eight years joe was the last one
in the room
whenever i faced a big decision and he
made me a better president
right he's got the character and the
experience to make us
a better country and he and kamala are
going to be in the fight not for
themselves but for every single one of
us
and we sure can't say that about the
president we've got right now
we could but we'd be lying you know
i i i i've said this before i never
thought donald trump would
embrace my vision i understood he didn't
agree with my policies
but i did hope for the country's sake
that he might show
some interest in the job
he might take the job seriously he never
has
he hasn't shown any interest in doing
the work
or helping anybody but himself and his
friends
or treating the presidency as anything
more than a reality show
to give him the attention that he craves
but unfortunately the rest of us have to
live with the consequences
almost 230 000 americans are dead
more than a hundred thousand small
businesses have closed
almost 300 300 000 jobs are gone in
michigan alone
america just had its single worst week
of new covet cases
and what's his closing argument here we
are the worst week
this week i mean we've been going
through this now for months
the federal government has had an
opportunity to respond four months
and his closing argument this week is
that
the press and people are too focused on
kovid
kohit he's jealous of kovitz media
coverage
and now he's accusing doctors of
profiting
off this pandemic think about that he
said this just yesterday
said doctors are overblowing it because
they're going to make money off it
doctors
would be funny if it weren't a tragedy
he does not understand the notion that
somebody
would risk their life to save others
without trying to make a buck
his chief of staff says we're not going
to control the pandemic
that's a quote said it last week true
mark meadows we're going to control the
pandemic we noticed
mr chief of staff we understand you're
not going to control the pandemic but
you know who will
joe biden will when we elect him
president of the united states
you remember when republicans were
saying let detroit go bankrupt you
remember that
now they might as well be saying let
america get coveted
because that's how they're asking if
trump were focused on kovit from the
beginning
cases wouldn't be reaching new record
highs across the country
and trump would be skating to reelection
some of the places he owes rallies have
even seen new spikes
after he leaves town there was just a
study
by stanford university that just came
out
showing thousands of people are likely
to have gotten sick
because of these rallies he's holding
what is his obsession
by the way with crowd size you notice
that
swell he's trying to make up for the
small size of his he's always wearing
hands this is the one measure he has of
success
he's still worrying about his
inauguration crowd being smaller than
mine
it really bugs him he talked about he's
still talking about that
does he have nothing better to worry
about
did no one come to his birthday party
when he was a kid
probably not actually i mean that's true
what what what's with
crowds well you know
i've i've had crowds before you know
have you had quite a few but but you
know when
a country's going through a pandemic
that's not what you're supposed to be
worrying about
and that's the difference between joe
biden
and trump right there trump cares about
feeding his ego
joe cares about keeping you and your
family safe
and alive and he's less interested in
feeding his ego
with having big crowds then he is making
sure he's not going around
making more and more people sick that's
what you should expect
from a president don't hold your breath
with you you can expect something
different from a reality tv star
but from a president you want them
to put you above
their own ego
look here's the truth michigan this
pandemic would have been challenging for
any president
but this idea that somehow this white
house has done anything
but completely screw this up is nonsense
wow banhammer's being dropped already
it's first case a lot of toxic people
around these last couple days in the
chat
bye-bye just a few miles up right
it's not close i may not be pointing
north
but canada's pretty close by
our mortality rate in the united states
is two and a half times higher
than canada yeah but we're getting great
marks
if we had the same percentage of folks
dying
in canada as we do here
nearly 90 000 americans
would have died instead of 230
000 americans he said that backwards
pandemic like canada did
right okay 140 000 of our fellow
americans
might still be alive today think about
that
think about that
and yet despite that last week when
trump was asked if he'd do anything
different he said not much
he said nothing really not much
can't think of anything
i listen i i understand the president
was was anxious to downplay because he
wanted to get credit for the economy
that he inherited
and zero blame for the pandemic he
ignored
but it doesn't work that way the job
doesn't work that way
tweeting at the tv doesn't fix things
making stuff up doesn't make people's
lives better
you've got to have a plan you've got to
put in the work
and along with the experience to get
things done joe biden has concrete plans
and policies that will turn our vision
of a better fairer stronger country
into reality imagine policy joe's not
going to screw up testing
joe's not going to call scientists
idiots he's not going to host super
spreader events around the country
what joe will do is get this pandemic
under control
with a plan to make testing free and
widely available
to get a vaccine every american costs
free
and make sure our front-line heroes
never have to ask
other countries for the equipment that
they need that's what joe biden will do
joe's plan will guarantee paid sick
leave for workers and parents affected
by the pandemic
he'll make sure that small businesses
in every community not just some
not just big corporations but small
businesses that hold our communities
together
and employ millions of americans can
reopen safely
donald trump likes to claim he built
this economy america created 1.5 million
more jobs
in the last three years of the obama
biden administration
than in his first three years
and that was before he could blame the
pandemic
joe biden and i with the help of a
democratic congress
rescued the auto industry gary peters
was there
he told us to bet on michigan
and we did and manufacturing in michigan
grew by 15 percent
over our last four years a lot of trolls
getting banned today guys
it's one of those days the manufacturing
hub of the world again it's up
one percent under his first four years
15 under obama biden
one percent under him that's michigan
right here
we handed him the longest streak of job
growth in american history
but the economic damage he inflicted by
botching the pandemic response
means he'll be the only president since
herbert hoover
to actually lose jobs herbert hoover
that's a long time ago
joe biden and gary peters know that the
key
to a strong economy isn't cutting more
taxes for billionaires
it's lifting up the prospects for
working americans
and joe's got a plan to create one
million new auto related jobs
by accelerating electric vehicle
production
by the way just to give you guys a sense
of what's going on donald trump
just wrapped up his speech that was
supposed to end an hour and 20 minutes
ago
trump was still speaking at his first
event
when he was already supposed to be
speaking at his second event this event
in reading pennsylvania or reading
pennsylvania i don't know how it's
pronounced in massachusetts reading is
pronounced reading
with regard to the town not reading is
reading if you're reading a book you
understand
um trump's three minutes late to his
second event
he's just now leaving his it's just what
what is going on in that administration
just at the micro and the macro no
uh coordinate just rambling endlessly
let's get back to obama for now and then
by the way we've got kamala in 25
minutes coming up or the shift worker
always on the edge of
getting laid off or the cancer survivor
who's worried
that her pre-existing conditions
protections will be taken away
let's talk about healthcare for a second
please
let's talk about health care for a
second policy
republicans love to say right before an
election that they'll protect your
pre-existing conditions that's what they
say
this is live yes well you know what joe
and i
actually protected them 10 years ago
with the affordable care act
and since we did so
with no help from republicans no votes
from republicans
republicans have tried to repeal or
undermine the aca more than 60 times
for 60 times they've tried to take
people's health care away
and when asked why are you why are you
doing that why are you being so mean
you don't think these people should have
health care to say no no no
we've got a new plan it's going to be
beautiful it's going to be terrific
except it's been 10 years now and they
still don't have a plan
they're trying to bamboozle you
instead of actually coming up with a
plan they've attacked the aca
at every turn they've they've driven up
costs
they've driven up the number of
uninsured now they're trying to get the
supreme court
to take your health care away in the
middle of a pandemic
in the mid right at the time when people
need health care
they they've signed on to a case right
now in the supreme court
where they're trying to take insurance
away from folks who need it
with nothing but empty promises to take
its place
and now mitch mcconnell is pouring
millions of outside super pac dollars
into michigan to try to beat gary peters
because that's part of their agenda
michigan here is the truth
joel and kamala and gary will protect
your health care
they will expand medicare they will make
insurance more affordable
for everybody and the reason you know
that's true is because they were there
when we did it the first time
when doing nothing is better for people
than what trump wants to do
you know what trump wants to do is
really
michelle and i were talking about this
over dinner the other day
you're not gonna have to think about
them every day imagine talking to your
wife during dinner
you're not gonna have to argue sir with
your family about them every day it
won't be so exhausting
you'll be able to get on with your lies
knowing that the president
is not going to suggest we inject bleach
as a possible cure of covet
um you won't have to find out
you won't you you won't wake up in the
morning and kind of open your phone
oh newsflash uh the president retweeted
conspiracy theories that the navy seals
didn't actually kill bin laden
right you're not going to have a
president who goes out of his way to
insult people
just because they don't support him
this is not normal behavior people
we would not tolerate it from a teacher
or a coach or a co-worker or a family
member
if if a neighbor is actually more
extreme than that a lot of
normal people if they behave like trump
it's a 72
psych hold and then maybe you get out if
you sign off that you'll stay on the
meds
you know what there are consequences to
this action
there are consequences to his actions
it's not just a joke
it's not funny those actions embolden
other people to be mean
and divisive and racist
and a phrase at the fabric of all of our
lives and it affects
how our children see the world and how
they treat each other
it affects the way our families get
along
it affects the way the world sees
america
that's why joe talks about the soul of
america
that's why he he talks about decency
and kindness and responsibility and hard
work
that more than anything is what
separates joe biden from his opponent he
actually cares about every american
he does not have a mean-spirited bone in
his body i have seen him
spend spend time with with people
that strangers that he doesn't know when
he hears about they're going through a
hardship he talks about what he's gone
through
when he sees a kid his eyes light up
because because he thinks about his own
kids and grandkids he
joe biden tries to live the values we
cherish
honesty hard work kindness humility
responsibility helping somebody else out
that used to be the definition of of
manliness
not strutting and showing off
acting important bullying people
used to be being a man meant taking care
of your
other people not going around bragging
but but just doing the work
not looking for credit
trying trying to live right passing on
those values to your kids
looking out for a community carrying
your weight
giving up a little bit of what what you
might have to help somebody who has
a real need
when you elect joe that's what you'll
see reflected from the white house
and those shouldn't be republican or
democratic values they didn't used to be
they're what we grew up learning from
our parents and from our grandparents
and they're the values we still try to
teach our kids and they're not
white or black or hispanic or asian or
native american values they're american
values
and we've got to reclaim them right now
but to reclaim them
we're going to have to turn out like
never before
if we're going to reclaim those values
we need to leave no doubt
we can't afford to be complacent not
this time
not in this election
we got a little complacent the last
election right
listen i understand why americans get
frustrated and sometimes think
government's not going to make a
difference voting is not going to make a
difference
i understand that government's not
perfect the people in government are not
perfect even when it's working
government's not going to solve every
problem
but we can make things better
a president can't by himself solve every
challenge facing
the economy here in flint or michigan
but if we elect people like gary peters
and dan kildee and we get a house and a
senate
joined with a white house that are more
focused on working people
and getting you the help that you need
they will make a difference
and some folks will get jobs that
wouldn't otherwise have jobs
and some folks will have health care
that wouldn't otherwise have health care
a president by himself can't eliminate
all racial bias
in our criminal justice system right you
need jared kushner to help with that
if we elect district attorneys and
states attorneys
and sheriffs focused on equality and
justice
and we once again have a justice
department and a civil rights division
in the justice department
that cares about these issues we can
make things better
and that's what voting's about not
making things
perfect but making things better right
it puts us on a track
so that generations from now we can look
back and say you know what
right about then things start getting
better again
the fact that you don't get 100 of what
you want right away
that's not a good reason to vote you
just got to keep at it
you know typically just over 50 of us
vote
who are eligible embarrassing
embarrassing almost
half of the people in most elections who
are eligible to vote
don't vote imagine if 60
of us voted imagine if 70
of us voted imagine
january 20th when we swear in a
president and vice president
who's got a plan to get us out of this
mess who care about
folks like you who've been in your shoes
who know what it's like to struggle who
know what it's like to have to work hard
are thinking about working americans and
have a plan to help you start getting
ahead
imagine what it's going to be like to
have a president and a vice president
who believe in science
and who have a plan to protect this
planet for our children and who believe
in
racial equality and are sending a
clear signal that we're all in this
together
and are doing the work to bring us
closer
so that we have an america where no
matter what we look like where we come
from who we love
or how much money we've got we we can
make it
and we have a place and we're treated
with dignity and respect
michigan that's what's possible
and i'm asking you to remember
that it's possible i want you to
remember what this country can be
but you can't just imagine a better
future you can't just wish for it
gotta do something
you gotta fight for it we gotta out
hustle the other side
we gotta vote up and down the ticket
like never before
right here in michigan and all across
the country
we've got to leave no doubt about who we
are
and what this country stands for and if
we do
we will send gary peters back to the
senate
and we will elect a man who loves this
country
and who cares about you and who will
fight
for every single one of us
and will look out not just for folks who
support him but even the folks who don't
my friend the next president
of the united states of america joe
biden
wow
little stevie wonder just to kick things
up remember donald trump
uh on his way look at biden go um
donald trump on his way to some lunatic
event we also have kamala harris
speaking right now we will go to kamala
uh after joe extremely bad audio and
video problems happening for kamala
harris but we're gonna hear from joe
biden
um i and for people asking about phones
i will
open phones we have a more modest goal
of 100 today that's website
members and twitch subs and i will open
phones if we get to it
let's hear from joe
the music's still gone
mr president okay so joe biden now
taking over from the music
kind of reminds you how good it can be
listening to him doesn't it
as my mother would say about barack god
love him he's a good man
folks it's good to be back with friends
mary neely governor whitmer lieutenant
governor gilchrist
debbie stabenow my good buddy gary
peters who you are going to send back to
the united states senate
come on cause i'm gonna need him we can
always count on him to be your senator
for you
and your family and my good friend
congressman dan kildee
who we need to send back the house dan's
a good man
a good man and of course i wish we could
figure out
how to send back a guy who uh
we used to have an expression in the up
in scranton
we'd say when someone wouldn't somebody
else is equal to there wasn't a patch on
his jeans
i tell you what mr president you're
still driving him crazy because he knows
he wasn't a patch on your jeans
i tell you what triggered barack
it's obama to be with the president
again
it reminds me of what we can be when you
have a president of character
a president respected around the world a
president our kids
looked up to and did look up to
i want to say something we don't say
often enough and i mean this from the
bottom of my heart
barack obama was a great president of
the united states of america
and i want to make sure we say it here
today
mr president thank you thank you thank
you
went through eight years without one
single trace of scandal not one single
trace of scandal i don't know
that bougie mustard he liked and the tan
sued and
i don't know and a little too much drone
three days
three days we can put an end to this
presidency we have now
that has divided the nation three days
we can put an end to a presidency that
has failed to protect this nation
three days we can put an end to this
presidency
that has fanned the flames of hate all
across this nation
and made us a laughing stock around the
world
millions of americans have already voted
millions more
are voting today tomorrow and god
willing all the way through to the close
of the polls on tuesday
and my message to you is simple the
power to change the country
is not figured it is literally in your
hands
i don't care how hard donald trump tries
there's nothing let me say it again
there's nothing that he can do to stop
the people of this nation
from voting in overwhelming numbers and
taking back this democracy
and when americans vote no matter how
many threats he makes
america will be heard when america is
heard
i believe the mission is going to be
loud and it's going to be clear
it's time for donald trump to pack his
bags and go home
well he'll but his butler will pack him
for him but we're done with the chaos
the tweets the anger the hate
the failure the refusal to take any
responsibility
we've got a lot of work to do we got a
lot of work to do
and if i'm elected you're president
we're gonna do it
we're gonna act and we're gonna need
your help in doing it as well
we're gonna act to get covert under
control on day one of my presidency i'll
put an action
a plan i've been taking about talking
about for months already laid out
a national mandate mask wearing social
distancing testing tracing
all things as president obama just said
that should have
could have been put in place months and
months ago
a plan for full and fair
and free i might add distribution of
therapeutics
and vaccines when we get one imagine
where we'd be
if we had a president of war mask
instead of mocking it
i can tell you this we wouldn't have
nine million confirmed cases of covert
in this nation
over 230 000 deaths we wouldn't be
seeing a new record of cases
we're seeing right now 90 000 cases
today yesterday 90 000 new cases
we wouldn't be by the way 500 000 and
it's just the past week
this guy tells us it's going away i
don't think he'll make it go away if he
goes away
folks
we wouldn't be facing another 200 000
deaths in the next few months
this president knew in january the virus
was deadly
and trying to
improve his image he went up tried to
talk to bob woodr he thought he could
change his mind
but what he did he let it be known
all the way back in january he knew how
dangerous this pandemic was
and he hid it from the american people
he knew it was worse than the flu
but he lied to the american people he
knew it wasn't going to disappear but he
kept telling us
a miracle is coming and yesterday
he had the goal to suggest that american
doctors
people are putting their lives on the
line on the front
lines to save other lives along with
nurses and so many others he suggested
falsely that they're inflating the
number of cova deaths
to make more money what in the hell is
wrong with this man
excuse my language but think about it
by easter this will be solved guys under
trump easter twenty twenty
because he doesn't do anything for other
than for money the people of this nation
have suffered and sacrificed
for nine months none more so than the
doctors on the front lines and
healthcare workers
and this president is questioning their
character their integrity
their commitment to their fellow
americans
it's more than offensive it's a disgrace
especially coming from a president who
has waived the white flag of surrender
to this virus our front-line health
worker he doesn't even really have a
flag that's the crazy thing
the virus we have a president who's just
given up
i will never raise the white flag of
surrender
we're going to beat this virus we're
going to get it under control
and the first step to doing that is
beating donald trump
look
donald trump keeps telling us what a
great job
he's done as president oh man
well did you know president obama and i
as he pointed out created more jobs in
the last three years of our
administration
than he did in the first three years
before the pandemic
how about this or did you know
donald trump's going to be the first
president in 90 years
to finish his term with fewer jobs under
his leadership
than when he started look that's a lot
of presidents
that's a lot of crises but only donald
trump
is going to have fewer jobs at the end
of his presidency than when he started
you see i and barack understand
something
donald trump doesn't wall street didn't
build this country
you did working people built this
country
and unions built the middle class
he's done nothing of wage war on
american labor
i see the uaw sign out there first
outfit
ever endorsed me in 19 when i was a 29
year old kid
god love you look
we have a different view we believe we
should be rewarding
work not wealth in this country
under my plan if you make less than 400
000 a year you're not going to pay a
penny in additional taxes
but the wealthiest people the biggest
corporations
91 of the fortune 500 companies paid
zero
in federal income tax last year
a respectful zero the super wealth are
going to pay the same rate they played
at the beginning of george bush's
administration
and corporations are going to start to
pay their fair share
why should a firefighter an educator a
nurse
pay the higher tax rate than someone
making literally a billion dollars
or should you why should you pay more in
taxes
than donald trump
he paid 750 dollars in taxes
the one year we know of he's yet to
release i've released 22 years of my tax
returns
you can go online and look he hasn't
released one
he talks about corruption what is he
hiding
he owes 41 million bucks out there
who's the owner 410 million 410 million
you notice
really 1.1 billion i know of that a
secret bank account in china
paid 50 times more taxes in beijing
than he's paid in the united states
right and this guy talks about
corruption
look we're also going to act to protect
health care
trump of the republicans just jammed
through a supreme court nominee
for one overwhelming reason
let's just take a quick listen to what
kamala harris is saying i do want to
hear a little bit from her as well how
difficult
it may be for some to hear we must
acknowledge racial disparities
we must acknowledge what the
virus has highlighted for example in in
our health care system
when african americans and latinos are
three times as likely to contract the
virus and twice as likely to die from it
when black women are three to four times
likely to die
in childbirth as compared to other women
when our native american brothers and
sisters have the highest rates of
diabetes of any population in our
country
we must speak truth about these things
and
address them with the motivation being
that we have to have a society that is
built
on a respect for the concept of equality
and reaching equality through
initiatives that are about achieving
equity
on the other hand you have
donald trump who
on the debate stage in the first debate
we all remember
refused to condemn white supremacists
and then went on to double down and talk
about stand
back and stand by and i think it's
really
important to put this in context and to
understand a pattern we have witnessed
a pattern that started before he was
running for president
where he questioned the legitimacy of
the first black president of the united
states
we're on the issue of charlottesville
where there were peaceful protesters
protesting
racial injustice in america all right so
we'll get back to that and hopefully
with better audio video sync but for the
time being let's stick with joe biden
dollars
out of medicare these guys mean what
they say
i'm going to protect social security
medicare and medicaid
because there's a lifeline for so many
hard-working folks
but folks i have to admit to you
it's kind of personal with me there's
nothing worse that this president has
done
in my view than the way he speaks about
our women and men in uniform and those
have given their lives right
they call them losers and suckers
my son beau was a major in the united
states army
gave up the attorney general's job and
petitioned to be able to go with his
unit to iraq
for one solid year after as a u.s
attorney
being in kosovo i might add i'm going to
be a typical dad
he's the only foreigner in kosovo
that has a 12-foot memorial
dedicated to him the major highway they
built
the bo biden highway because of his
commitment
my son came home with a bronze star that
could speak of his service but like so
many others
before he passed away but less what
he wasn't a sucker he wasn't a loser nor
any of you served
you're patriots and just like all of
your sons and daughters
your parents and grandparents who served
the president likes to portray himself i
love this
likes to portray himself as a tough guy
when you're in high school wouldn't you
have liked to take the shot anyway it's
a different story but yeah
macho man oh biden's gonna get crushed
for that but that is funny
you read about saul heard about a
present united states
oh man literally being laughed at by
world leaders
when he spoke with the united nations
laughed at out loud
why when's the last time you saw
president united states
being hopefully mocked by the leaders of
nato
at a nato conference and can you believe
we have a president
who acts like vladimir putin's puppy
putin put bounties on the heads of
american soldiers serving in iraq
and trump was too scared to challenge
him talked to him six times never
mentioned it no no trump says he's very
strong with the other dictators
he commands a little respect for the
international stage
this the president who not only doesn't
understand sacrifice
you don't understand courage physical
courage
it takes to serve in uniform in a war
zone
maybe that's why six generals and
admirals who worked for him
left his administration and said he was
unfit
to command be commander-in-chief when's
the last time
any president has had that happen tough
guy
that's why george special operations
commander
general stanley mcchrystal that's why
head of the navy seals oversaw the raid
of bin laden admiral bill craven
and 22 other four stars have endorsed me
saying they support me to be their next
commander-in-chief
because like obama and bush and before
him
they know we respect them we'll support
them
i've been in and out of war zones as
senator and vice president
over 35 times
i tell you what these folks we have only
one percent
of the country is in the military
we owe them they're the backbone they're
the sinew they're the
heart of who we are the sinew i like
that
why we have to support our military
not a word trump knows i can assure you
folks
you know i want to tell you something
think about this this is a guy
who says there's no such thing as
climate change
he calls it a hoax
i see it as jobs health and safety
the impacts on climate are too often
fall disproportionately
on poor communities and communities of
color
we're going to make sure communities
benefit from the hundreds of billions of
federal investment
and infrastructure and climate change
we're going to do as a consequence of
the change in the structure
we're going to create local jobs to
rebuild roads
fill sidewalk cracks install broadband
create
spaces to live work and play safely to
modernize infrastructure so you can
turn on the faucet and clean water comes
out and when that happened in flint
will never happen again anywhere in
america but will you have to flush 15
times like trump
we can't and must do this donald trump
has rolled back more than 100
environmental protection laws
many enacted under barack and me
this also holds polluted i'll call
polluters accountable
with the most ambitious environmental
justice agenda ever
folks we're an act to deliver on racial
justice in america
protesting is not burning or looting
violence has cannot be tolerated and it
won't but
these protesters is a cry for justice
the names of george florida taylor jacob
blake
will not soon be forgotten they're going
to inspire a new wave of justice in
america
america has had their eyes opened up
they're ready
look i believe this country has to come
together i know when i announced
well over a year ago when i said i
wanted to unite the country everybody
said that's naive
that was a long time ago you did it
before biden but you can't do it again
well we can and we must we have no
choice
that's how democracies work i'm running
as a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work as hard for those who don't
support me as those who do
that's the job of a president it's a
duty to care
a duty to care for everyone so please
vote you still have an absentee ballot
get it to a drop box as soon as you can
dropbox
you could also safely vote early until
monday afternoon
or you can vote election day just make a
plan
help get out the vote as he's heard us
10 times already visit iwillvote.com
mi folks
we have such an incredible opportunity
well god love you thank you very much
but here's the deal guys we got to vote
up and down the ticket here
i honest to god believe i give you my
word as abide and i honest to god
believe
we're in the cusp we're in an inflection
point we have a chance to make such
enormous progress
because the american people have seen
what the other looks like
they've gotten a glimpse of the abyss i
really mean it
it's dark they're ready they're ready to
change
so much i'll never forget what president
kennedy said when he promised to send us
to the moon
he used the phrase that has guided me
he said we're doing it because quote
we refuse to postpone well i refuse to
postpone the incredible opportunities
to the united states of america for the
american people
there is nothing beyond our capacity
there is no limit to america's future
the only thing that can tear america
apart is america
itself and that's exactly what donald
trump has been doing
from the beginning of this campaign
dividing america
pitting americans against one another
based on race gender ethnicity
national origin it's wrong it's not
american that's
not who we are folks
everybody knows who donald trump is
let's keep showing though who we are
we choose hope over fear we choose unity
over division
we choose science over fiction
and yes we choose truth over lies
wow my fellow americans it's time for us
to stand back
and stand up and take back our democracy
we can do this we're so much better than
we've been
we can be where we are at our best the
united
states of america god bless you
all and may god protect our troops thank
you thank you thank you
so there is uh joe biden wrapping up a
speech in flint michigan introduced by
former president barack obama and then
now
joe biden putting on a hat and maybe
soon a mask
on to the next event it is wall-to-wall
rallies all day today donald trump
already an hour and a half behind after
uh trump's an hour in and somehow he's
90 minutes behind
uh joe biden um
there he is okay doing something with
barack obama there
and uh barack obama very strongly
wearing a mask as you can see which says
vote what a day ladies and gentlemen 72
oh wait hold on
24 48 72 yeah 72
plus 4 76 hours
until it will be announced
that joe biden has won north carolina
now maybe that's a little bit optimistic
biden forgot his mask now looking for it
maybe it's in his pocket we don't know
uh patting himself down and soon i'm
sure someone will get him where did
where did i put that thing
there it is there is the mask
and joe biden putting it on and that is
it that is a wrap there so we are now
standing by
donald trump was scheduled 45 minutes
ago actually let's see if i can do
trump reading pa rally
that's the next one let me see if i can
find an event
so right this is some kind of event here
pen that's two weeks ago let me see if i
can find
reading pennsylvania we've got that
stream going already
uh where is that stream
trump let's see if i just do trump rally
today
it's scheduled for any moment now but
we're going to go to it
man these events it's just these these
why isn't it clearer you have to
sometimes it's like halfway down
38 minutes ago okay so we want reading
um i'm guessing it'll crop up eventually
okay so this is this is waiting for
trump someplace and then this is
waiting for trump no this one's over so
that's done
we've got kamala but the audio is
totally out of sync okay all right
listen i'm doing the best i can to keep
up with all these different things
trump search trump live people are
telling me
okay let me see here
trump right side broadcasting channel is
totally toxic
39 minutes ago one day ago
four days ago we want scheduled for like
very soon
news now from fox let's see what they've
got going right now
uh this is still biden
walking around no that's delayed that
was biden looking for his mask
right side broadcasting this is a
different event
my god one day ago
all right well sometimes you know so
let's see trump
fox news reading
four days ago one day ago two hours ago
all right we got listen we've got two
streams i think these will be okay for
the time being
um we're standing by for for donald
trump here
okay good so welcome back everybody if
you've been
watching and and uh observing we are
down to just the very very
end of this entire thing uh i do what
let me get caught up so many people have
signed up and i want to get caught up on
numbers so
we had uh 11 people
sign up via twitch and they count
towards our goal of 100 to open phones
okay so that gets us to 12
then we've got on my website which is
the best way to sign up
join pacman.com nick stevens is number
13.
bridgette heren is number 14.
leanne goodman is number 15
mara paz calderon is number 16
christy massey is number 17 and
christopher lazard is number 18.
uh and i do invite you wall-to-wall
coverage we've had debates we've had
rallies we've had biden trump
obama we've had everything and we will
have live election coverage for you on
tuesday
support the work we do really it does
actually mean a lot
um join pakman.com the coupon code above
my head
is done on tuesday we're it is over
20 20 now saves you 66
and it is over over over
over on tuesday um
another postponement of this rally now i
guess until 3 15
p.m eastern we're standing by for all of
it what a day
okay let's now get to some of the
different
things that i wanted to talk about let
me just go if do you guys mind if i go
right to my map because otherwise i'll
just never have time
it's just uh let's start with a blank
map uh we keep running out of time for
this and i actually do want to get to do
i i have not done this so allow me the
time i need to actually think through
what my map would would look like then
we will get caught up on new members and
we'll open the phone lines if we've
achieved our target okay
alaska's going red and hawaii is going
blue
i feel very very strong about that
washington oregon or oregon as trump
says and california are definitely going
blue
uh massachusetts rhode island
connecticut jersey delaware maryland dc
all going blue vermont of course going
blue
new york going blue virginia going blue
west virginia will be red
indiana red illinois blue tennessee will
be red
kentucky red south carolina red alabama
red
mississippi louisiana arkansas missouri
minnesota will be blue the dakotas will
be red nebraska will be red
although i actually think there's a
chance nebraska's second district goes
blue we will see
uh kansas oklahoma will be red
montana idaho wyoming red utah
very red colorado will be blue new
mexico
blue okay so here's where we're starting
oh i'm sorry and and maine is going uh
maine is going i believe maine is going
to go fully blue there's some thought
about
one district in maine going red i think
maine's going blue
i just think it's blue okay now let's
actually look at some of the polling on
these okay
so let me um let's pull up so i i
i'm thinking nevada is going to be very
powerfully blue
right now the numbers are biden plus
four uh but that includes biden plus two
from trafalgar
i believe that nevada is is ultimately
going to go blue
um arizona i'm feeling pretty confident
on blue as well
um oh no but trump's now up in there
wow so actually arizona may not let's do
arizona red just for our math
now i see people saying minnesota is a
question
i i don't know about that guys if you
actually look at the polling
um biden's up and even
you know even trafalgar says it's biden
plus three and that's part of the
i think minnesota is going blue i don't
um
i i don't think there's any any doubt
about that uh okay
wisconsin and michigan have been topics
of much discussion
and when we look at the wisconsin
numbers there's a lot of claims that you
know
last time hillary was winning wisconsin
and trump won the difference is
in the 10 days before the 2016 election
trump was trending up in wisconsin
trump is now trending down in wisconsin
so it's very different similarly if you
look at michigan
trump versus biden again
uh trump won michigan last time and by
the way the average of 6.5
depends on this red red uh you know
republican poll that says trump plus 2.
um there is a spike here for trump in
michigan
so i am much more sure about wisconsin
going blue than i am
michigan so let's come back to michigan
in a little bit
okay then we've got iowa
iowa trump versus biden iowa is very
close right now
man this website is slow right now oh my
goodness didn't did it just freeze up it
didn't
so biden has a slight lead in iowa but
it's very very close
it's very very close um we do have the
georgia situation
now 538 has actually now in it
where does a real clear politics have it
georgia has biden ahead
and and 538 has biden ahead in georgia
i think if we're reasonable we have to
say georgia goes red
i right i mean i think we any we can't
have a path for biden that depends on
georgia going going blue i just don't i
just don't think so although
it's possible that georgia will go blue
i will get back to that
then we have north carolina trump versus
biden
biden is now up slightly in north
carolina
again that's with rasmussen saying trump
is ahead
that's um with trafalgar saying trump is
ahead
let's just give trump north carolina
okay
and then i'm gonna get back to it let's
give trump iowa
let's give trump ohio i think new
hampshire is very very much
at this point in uh oh my god what is
happening here
hold on new hampshire trump biden
biden's way ahead in new hampshire i
don't think it's even going to be a
question
so we're going new hampshire blue so
understand that in this scenario why am
i stopping here
okay in this scenario um
if joe biden were to get florida it's
over
okay so with these states left as
question marks
trump could get michigan pennsylvania
and texas
if biden just gets florida biden wins
okay let's move him back to
undecided and there we go if
out of these four states the impossible
happens and biden gets texas
it's over okay and then
if he gets michigan and pennsylvania
it is also over even if if trump gets
texas and florida
so what is the path for donald trump
here well the path for donald trump here
is
he gets texas and florida
and north carolina and pennsylvania so
here is one scenario that could come
down to pennsylvania
if he doesn't get pennsylvania but he is
able to get michigan
he also wins so there really are a bunch
of different scenarios where this come
could come down to pennsylvania and
michigan
now i know some of you are saying well
what what about what if biden gets texas
or what if biden gets georgia what if
biden gets north carolina
then it's over you understand then trump
can get all of this stuff you could even
give trump
listen if biden gets texas and north
carolina
give trump florida give trump
pennsylvania give
trump michigan give trump wisconsin give
trump minnesota
if biden gets texas and north carolina
it is dunzo
um so there are a lot of scenarios here
for joe biden
there still are scenarios for donald
trump
obviously uh if donald trump gets all of
this stuff he wins but i don't think
trump gets minnesota
i just really don't um arizona's also a
question by the way
arizona is also a question biden can get
himself arizona
in which case trump absolutely needs to
get pennsylvania
and something else he either needs to
actually no
even with michigan in wisconsin he'd oh
oh georgia okay
so then if you put georgia back and the
reality is there's a reason that this is
very fraught
because we're acting like each state is
its own election
in the sense that there aren't going to
be trends obviously
if biden gets georgia it seems extremely
unlikely
that trump gets wisconsin and michigan
so like this is not a likely scenario
because if georgia goes blue wisconsin's
going blue and michigan's going blue
and then arizona may go blue and then
pennsylvania i mean it starts to get
completely crazy i don't think we should
plan on any of these scenarios
uh i think we should plan on the
narrowest possible path
and understanding that it really could
come down to pennsylvania
uh and and michigan uh quite frankly and
we're gonna be watching
those states extremely closely i mean
just
so powerfully we're gonna be watching
all of those uh
okay let's see if we have any new trump
reading
streams ready to go doesn't seem as
though we do
um but we still have
working streams that we are waiting on
even if one of them is this wacky right
side broadcast oh my god they're playing
clips of obama
at a trump rally can you imagine okay
let me let me get caught up and then i'm
going to read some
um oh mark says you're going to have to
open the phone's pack why let's see
uh okay so twitch we've got 11 39
that's plus one that gets us to
19 and then over
on the website oh well there are things
happening on the website okay
caitlyn forbes is new member number 20.
hilary silas is new member number 21
sam carl is new member number 22 emily
o'neil number 23
jeremy patrick 24 doreen
khan 25 and bert
haver is new member number 26. yeah
yesterday we
we decided to include twitch subs
in our goal yesterday but the goal was
125 and we fell
short for phones um today we have a goal
that is much more modest it is at 100
and website subscriptions count join
pacman.com
and twitch subscriptions count as well
and
uh oh 11 40 that gets us to 27.
all right good let me now apologize
profusely
and get to some of the super chats that
are coming in
um do i have any new spanish clips
no i do have i don't know how many of
you follow me on instagram
if you don't follow me on instagram you
really should
uh you can see me voting you can see me
harvesting my tomatoes and lots of stuff
but i did post a clip from my spanish
language show yesterday this is the
great actor
jaime camille known from such shows as
jane the virgin and many many other
shows
he did an act an argentinian accent for
us
on the upcoming episode that's going to
air this sunday
check this out this was great fun for
the spaniards
okay so very very exciting stuff and
he's a big progressive activist really
really good guy and by the way fan
of the david pakman show he explained to
me
that he's a fan of the david pakman show
he watches the clips he's a fan of tyt
and so on and so forth so a very very
exciting day as you can imagine
huge win huge win
in the battle of the churning of ideas
as many of you can imagine
just an extremely it was the play of the
game it was there was no doubt about it
it was it was the play of the game
uh hook line sinker
full stop period end of story i think we
have to apply all metaphors
and similes to that okay we are standing
by for donald trump
scheduled for an hour ago
ran 90 minutes late at his previous
rally
who the hell knows if we will ever see
trump i mean it's completely
unclear uh if we will ever see him
let's start getting to some super chats
okay malik says heard the comments of
michael moore that the danger is the
trump supporters rather not take part in
the polls
so if there are states that are close
there's an imminent danger that the
states
swing red absolutely a possibility which
is why we all have to vote
no doubt whatsoever
wait what's going on in butler
pennsylvania now hold on a second let's
look at trump's schedule today now i'm
confused
so trump delivers remarks
at a rally about making america great
again again
that was in upper makefield township
that was earlier so that already
happened
newton pa okay trump then it's like
reading these schedules
you need you need a a ti-83 to do it
then trump is going to reading which is
where we are right now
then trump is going to butler oh so hold
on a second
the butler rally is already going even
though it's it's two hours from now oh
and this is not even live let me close
that that's just trash
so they've got a guy talking at the
butler rally that's not even the next
round
who the hell knows i mean it's really
hard to know what is going on at this
point
um okay other super chats coming in jrp
says good on you for getting my name
right
jeromy jeremy keep up the great work
love it
patricio says can i get a shout out to
my best buds tito
and junior tito finally voting yes
first time ever after years of being
eligible junior powerfully voting
through the mail
because of a positive covid test so
proud of them
absolutely everybody must vote love it
joseph dinsey says his propaganda videos
in the middle of trump's rallies are
just like the two-minute hate from 1984.
has his staff taken notes from ingsoc
yes it's very dystopian daraten says
austin most conservative state swung
left aus
oh australia's most conservative state
swung left today
all right um mark says i'm going to have
to open the phones
well we're we're at 27. force me to open
them please
josiah says can you please say trans
rights thanks love your show just said
it
um that's become i guess a meme i don't
know me saying trans rights
aaron says my father's doing a
contactless halloween where kids will
get candy slid through a small slide
that pokes through a plastic flap i've
heard of a lot of people doing that
that is interesting uh tristan says
pronounced redding like the color red
yeah i so in massachusetts we have a
redding that is spelled like reading and
it's pronounced
reading i just didn't know if in
pennsylvania it was reading or reading
but now people told me
it's reading so now i'm pronouncing it
correctly
ant and sharon say vote biden harris get
trump out truth over lies
elias wants to know if i heard about ice
sterilizing women in georgia i heard
about ice sterilizing women
and i believe it's a doctor from georgia
but i wasn't sure that they were
it was taking place in georgia that is
interesting um
something happening here who knows
daraten says trump knows sinew they
swell with
bone spurs well said
josephine says biden looks cool
lisa asks if trump's just mailing it in
at this point it's almost sad to watch
him especially seeing biden who actually
cares
um well said yeah i i think trump is not
mailing it in but i think he's been
demoralized
what's this about by the way is trump
now on some smaller subs
it's like a matryoshka russian dolls
subsequent smaller planes
uh trump uh showing up in increasingly
small planes is that what's going on
hard to say i'd really like to get off
of this
stream because it's just so vile but
let's see if we can find a new stream
58 minutes ago
two out this is live from two hours ago
waiting for fox news
oh okay that's good so we've got at
least one other one
and let's see what else we can find uh
other streams
okay i feel i feel better now so we've
got the fox news stream
we do have this right side broadcasting
stream
and then we've got the sun stream i'm
feeling
better now about the streams that we
have for you guys good
very very good um also a big thank you
to zev butler
zev is new member number 28 at
joinpakman.com
and we also have an additional five
remember twitch counts now
twitch counts gets us to 33.
uh a third of the way there to opening
the phone lines beautiful
okay other super chats coming in uh
let's see
here um mike says will obama be part of
biden's administration i don't think so
it is not typical for former presidents
to then take lower positions like
i was getting messages from people
saying you know um there should really
be
a secretary of state barack obama it's
just not traditional
it's just not traditional that that's
the way it's done cody says
pseudoleftists and neolibs have their
boots on the throat
of the progressive movement returning to
normal is insane
adapt and adapt and vote or fail
i can't tell if that's an
accelerationist type argument cody or
what
but uh okay mark says
you have to have 100 new members to open
the phones i hope there are that many
people that do that well
the we've had 150 and 200 new members
during streams
many times and then we've had during the
first
debate we had like i believe it was 368
it was a magical night a magical evening
368 i think it was
square circle uh sending a super chat
shannon says can you please explain how
biden's proposed
changes in 401k policy might work so
my recollection is shannon and i'd have
to look into it
the amount that the there's going to be
if you are oh okay i wanna i wanna
really be as clear as possible
above a certain income only
part of your 401k contribution would be
tax deductible
right now your full 401k contribution is
tax deductible
um and there are limits on how much you
can contribute
the biden idea is you can still
contribute as much as you currently can
no matter your income but only part of
it would be tax deductible
it would basically make a difference of
like from what i saw
a few a couple thousand bucks for very
wealthy people
very small uh impact but uh
very very revenue positive for sure
square circle asks if donald trump is an
alien
okay 28 days later says hey david new to
your channel the only progression
progressive issue i don't agree with is
gun control but other than that i'm
on board well when you say you don't
agree with gun control
that is a uh that is a it's a losing um
uh catalyst for a conversation what
exactly don't you agree with you don't
agree with
universal background checks you don't
agree with limiting anything like our
shoulder mounted rpgs should
should individuals be allowed to own uh
nukes or blackhawk helicopters
so uh to say i don't agree with gun
control
you're gonna have to be a little more
specific with me tell me exactly which
proposed policy
you don't agree with um
and that for people saying nukes aren't
guns a lot of the things that are
available today
were not what would have been considered
arms
back in uh uh when whatever year the
second amendment is from okay
all right it looks like things are
getting going here
um there is donald trump landing
extremely strongly
uh okay in the little plane today in the
757
there we go and we are standing by for
donald trump okay
other super chats coming in alex the
wizard says i can't help get to the 100
members
because i'm already a member that is sad
the dude says i've started seeing more
biden signs up here in northeastern
pennsylvania but we've also seen 40 plus
cases per day since the rally in erie
time for this [ __ ] to go
greg says urgently sipping on coffee
while we wait for the rally thank you
for the company and the content
by the way this is well i guess
this isn't sponsored in the sense that
they don't sponsor my live streams but
we
got or i don't even know if they've can
i say this
i actually i know i've recorded the ads
but i don't know if they've started
four sigmatic mushroom coffee which is
like a blend of ground up mushroom
and regular coffee started advertising
on my podcast which is not this like i'm
mentioning it here just because i had
some this morning
uh it's actually pretty good i'm like
really more of an espresso guy
but on the weekend sometimes i'll pull
out my chemex and do a little bit of a
science experiment
it's actually good it's it's i mean who
would think
mushroom coffee would be good but it's
actually quite good
okay uh let's see andrew says any bets
on how violently trump will try to hold
on to the white house after a biden
victory
violently i mean i don't think it's
going to get physically violent
but i do think uh donald trump is going
to do whatever he can
to remain in power and we need to be
ready for not knowing who wins
on uh tuesday and we need to be ready
for donald trump claiming victory no
matter what that's the thing to really
be prepared for
trump will claim that he won unless it
is a complete and total blowout on
a tuesday which it may not be because
we're not going to have final numbers
from a lot of different states
so uh just be prepared for tuesday i'm
i'm thinking that when i go off the air
it may get to 11 p.m when california
closes and whatnot
and by 1105 that may be it for the night
where we're not going to get any more
state calls
state calls until the next day we may
but we may not and we just have to be
ready for that
okay um what else do we have going on
uh i see a lot of people trying to get
me to
pick them up on a discord
guys we're not taking calls right now on
discord you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com
discord but we will take calls if we get
to 100
website members and twitch subs
okay so remember the number one way
to support our work is to sign up at
joinpakman.com if you've been enjoying
what we've been doing for the last
weeks months years however long you've
been with us uh
grab a membership at joinedpakman.com
you will see the blue bar fill up
i will thank you i will say you're a
great person even if i don't know that
for a fact
and we will get one member closer to
opening the phone lines and of course
the coupon code 2020 now is done so on
tuesday it'll the 2020 election is over
tuesday
sort of at least the voting and the
coupon code is done
done so these are the last opportunities
to get that coupon code going um
where is this rally this is in reading
pennsylvania reading pennsylvania
all right gordon says oh wait no hold on
um
so it's like i missed a bunch here i'm
sorry okay michael says so sick of the
hypocrisy they say freedom america only
when it applies to their ideologies
if it doesn't controlling choice is the
play of course
they want freedom assuming freedom is in
line with their ideology
and if it's not like gay marriage or
woman's right to choose or whatever
then all of a sudden well no no that's
crazy the federal government has to get
involved in that
matthew says talk about the trumpest
attack on the biden bus tour yeah i did
earlier
uh i had an article about that where is
it here it is
it was absolutely insane there was
actually some
sideswiping that happened these trump
maga
clowns in pickup trucks um surrounding
the biden
bus and there was actually a little bit
of a uh there was a sideswipe
incident for lack of a better term
ankit ankit says do you think trump
rallies are a cause for a third spike
no i mean the the rallies are causing
cases but it's not the number you know
we had a hundred thousand new cases
yesterday
they're not causing that number of cases
28 days later says universal background
checks for all purchases
including private transfers is as far as
i would go anything past that is a no-go
for me
okay i'm on board with universal
background checks and i would go beyond
that to some degree
um let me
see here oh so heads up to the
moderators
in both youtube and uh and twitch
let's closely monitor the anti-science
stuff that's being said in chat and if
people are obviously being sarcastic
about anti-science stuff regarding masks
or whatever
we can allow it but if there's actual
anti-trump
i'm sorry anti like anti-mask
anti-science
stuff and spreading disinformation we're
gonna have to drop the band hammer guys
because we can't we can't have that i
can't have that in good conscience
on my live streams i know sometimes it's
tough like someone just said masks kill
but there's a little haz chud
icon and they're also a subscriber so
i'm guessing that that's an obvious
uh i'm guessing that's an obvious joke
um
okay very good let's continue the luck
hunter says wouldn't it be smart for
biden to declare himself a single term
president
mendoza wow mendoza i've been to mendoza
argentina
went to some uh fantastic
wineries had some wine lunches
and all sort of sorts of stuff okay that
was satirical good very good
um okay i i don't know i think it
let's talk about that after the election
is how i would address that question
if trump loses will he too be too ill to
go to jail
good quest i like how you're wrapping up
like three different things into that
good question
kevin sebeggi says if you're not vegan
why not and if not why are you okay with
animals being exploited tortured and
killed
we're not doing it right now um the the
reason i'm not vegan
is well outlined in uh michael pollan's
book omnivore's dilemma
okay uh thank you very very much
and by the way oh well we're not gonna
get into it but
okay let's not even get into it okay
elias says can you back go back and read
my comment at the top
i did elias
did i hear about i sterilizing women in
georgia i did
i addressed that comment already i don't
see any other comment
linda says so disgusting trump's rally
content is always filled with lies
name calling and hatred more disgusting
is his base believing this
is administration policy
um tyler says what is the important
state biden needs to win
i mean pennsylvania looks like it could
come down it could come down to
pennsylvania
so we're looking a lot at pennsylvania
jerry says greetings from canada thanks
for the great coverage it should be an
interesting week ahead
indeed it should serge says could trump
be taken out of the white house in cuffs
no it's not going to happen aaron says
based on early voting it looks like
north carolina will be
blue for 2020. yeah we we've got to be
really careful with that
uh let me see if i can find the north
carolina numbers
um hold on how can i get the specific
north carolina numbers
oh i guess i can't okay i'd have i i'm
guessing the numbers are available but
on a different website right
uh do they have oh no here we go
detailed statistics
north carolina here we go okay uh total
voted
oh we want uh in-person votes okay so
in person in north carolina is tied
right now
between democrats and republicans and 30
independents okay mail-in ballots
returned ballots democrats winning 45 to
20.
yeah so listen this is this is important
but remember that the in-person election
day vote
is expected to be very heavily pro-trump
north carolina oh but no oh but 91 of
the 2016 vote is already in
[ __ ] i think we should be cautious but
that is looking pretty damn good for
north carolina i'm not gonna lie that
actually is looking pretty pretty solid
but we've all got a vote anything could
happen
all right let me do some other thank
yous as they are coming in
um let's see here ben
smith is new member number 34.
donnell bergeson is new member number 35
matt bellmore is number 36
rebecca butler is new member number 37
dana taylor 38 laurel rosenberg
39 and susan stewart
is number 40. then let's also add in
our twitch subscribers of which there
are five
more which puts us at 45 nicely done
nicely done as we await donald trump in
reading pennsylvania
um let's see what else we've got
allen's is watching very powerfully from
scotland on it
mark says he won't go vegan because he
can't get over his ego
just just you
i don't even understand that dylan says
okay so this seems to be some kind of
strange translation i'll just do it in
english because it seems like a google
translate
i can't imagine how much the economy has
suffered in tijuana
mexico thanks to the xenophobic policies
of donald trump
greetings from tijuana nice
nice omar says wish there was a way to
measure the impact of borat too on voter
attitudes if there was any
because the timing of its release was
honestly brilliant
the timing was was brilliant yeah
um frickshawn asks via twitch sub
whether i agree the democrats didn't do
enough to stop amy coney barrett
i think they didn't do enough but i
think there wasn't that much more they
could have done i think the problem is
there was a lot of posturing as if they
were going to do a ton
there really wasn't that much they could
do uh
and then they didn't do anything so it's
sort of like a combination of of all of
the above uh
situations quite frankly let's take a
listen and see what the
ambiance is like at this event
unbelievable beyond parody you you
really you can't satirize it it's
impossible
completely impossible to satirize um
okay uh oh somebody says i miss them
when i
in the member thank yous oh seb gibbs
seb is i wonder if that's sebastian
is number 46 and then
samir mejia is number 47
and i do think i am completely caught up
am i yes i'm completely caught up at
this point
uh good all right
talar says voted in person with my
parents very powerfully in michigan for
the big man biden
unfortunately early voting is not
looking good for democrats worried
i'm i'm very worried about michigan yeah
because when i looked at the data
um in terms of polling
michigan is closer than i would like to
see
um particularly the spike is what i'm
worried about because this is what we
saw in 2016
which was hillary was ahead but trump
had momentum at the in the last 10 days
we're seeing the momentum and in
addition to that if you look at michigan
data you see that uh wait a second
returned and accepted
oh do we not have partisan info here
requested
oh damn we don't have the michigan
partisan info okay well in any case i
agree that uh there's a real question
mark
around michigan i am completely in
agreement with you on that
the dude says what do you think the
impact of the lincoln project and other
ads has
had to sway republicans to vote for
biden biden is
close to a republican himself biden's
not close to a republican himself no
that's not true
but biden is certainly not as left as
bernie sanders that we can agree on
i don't really know the effect of the
lincoln project i i don't know that
we'll ever be able to measure it
mark says just like you david it was a
joke the people
who all angry at you for not being vegan
just can't get past
their egos oh i see what you're saying
mark i understand
eat man says imagine trump says the
biden
ambush was heroic yeah
waller is me you just hit 1.07
million subscribers is that true
um it is true oh wow yeah
yeah so my goal is 1.1 million by
election day but we need 10
000 subscribers a day between now and
then i don't see
any way that that uh is gonna happen
i just don't see it but it would be wild
it would be wild serge
says the other day you said presidents
don't go to prison that means trump
really did get away with obstruction of
justice
r.m even said he's guilty um
it's just not in the united states there
is no tradition
of prosecuting presidents my prediction
is it's not going to change with trump
that's just my prediction
i could be wrong ep says just on news of
the trump caravan running biden bus and
volunteers out of texas be careful out
there everyone
we have to be careful i'm very worried
about real world violence uh on
tuesday wednesday thursday friday uh
very very worried
very worried hey um i want to say thanks
to philip harding young
who is new member number 48 today
brian duncan the second is new member
number 49.
katherine pedork pedorke is new member
number 50
and sherry starkey is new member number
51
we also have one additional member
coming in via twitch sub that gets us to
52. twitch subs count
my friends uh you guys are not chopped
liver
you understand and in fact a lot of
interesting things happening on twitch
in the next few months uh
okay very good i'm wondering if i'm the
butt of some kind of inside joke that
i'm not understanding
michael says i had this hope that the
tick tock community pulls
one more epic troll register as a
republican then vote for biden would be
amazing
that wouldn't be bad that wouldn't be
bad and in fact i don't know how many of
you know
we are on tick tock now um
we post audio visual elements to
tick-tock
landon says thoughts on the recent
greenwald resignation you know i really
find myself not caring about it i i
think
um i actually i think that glenn
greenwald has been having some pretty
significant personal issues over the
last year to year and a half
and i think that that actually
is as much a factor in how
we've in the public presence of glenn
greenwald over the last six
six to 12 months um then
any sort of like political realignment
or anything like that
um anyway yeah that that's my thought i
don't i don't really have too much else
to say about it
like now he'll do sub stack and make
money with it good for him
uh tlar says what are the odds trump
wins only the electoral college again
well
i don't think there's any if you say i
would probably take
um i would probably take
20 to one odds on biden winning the
popular vote
but elektor the only thing trump has a
shot at
i believe is winning the electoral
college i don't think he's getting the
popular vote
um arizbot says ravioli
ravioli give me the formuoli
oh my god gabby says i became
a member did not hear my name uh
okay so we're talking about website
members
and i've i've listed everybody other
than michael
guy lee who is new member number 53
today
michael guy lee is number 53. here is
the mango menace
himself in reading pennsylvania let's
listen to the crowd
and that song is just um ubiquitous
jillian duncan
is new member number 54 which i
appreciate
and then we do have two more people
coming in via twitch
which puts us at 56. i love it 56 is a
great number
um and we are going to hear from donald
trump at another
corona rally very soon
i don't know how long he is expected to
go you can usually go by the temperature
current temperature reading pa
45 okay with low chance of precipitation
so i think it's very likely trump will
go a long time
a long time uh because the weather is
not particularly offensive to him
here is donald trump grabbing some
hats and he's going to toss them to the
crowd now
uh and
it it can you imagine that this is the
world we live in right now i mean
seriously
this is the world we live in now look at
this guy
we have we must depose him and there's
maskless mark meadows always in tow
uh oh my god
this is just this is just bad
oh my god um
it's it's beyond you know you can't
satirize this it's it's cultist insanity
trump now pointing at some people uh
all right well let's listen i guess and
see what was going to be on his mind
today see how triggered he is by obama's
speech
oh is there double audio happening right
now hold on no there isn't okay let's
close this
out
the video quality is atrocious i
apologize guys
look at all those cameras over there can
you show them us
you know can you show this crowd
they never talk about our crowd and in
reverse
they never talk about sleepy joe's crowd
either it's about
12 12 people just showed up 12.
look at this crowd maybe you could take
those cameras and just show over there
and over there more obsession with the
size of his
hello pennsylvania
great education and also hello reading
we know it well we know well three days
from now we are going to win
the commonwealth of pennsylvania and we
are going to win
four more great years in the white house
look at mark meadows with no mask in the
background there he is
they're getting a little nervous back
there you know the fake is
because florida's looking very strong
florida and this is not suppression
polls these are like you know voters
real polls that say trump's great
florida's looking very good
north carolina is looking very good ohio
is looking beyond good
ohio you ever hear you can't win
unless you win the great state of ohio
did you ever hear that
for republicans that's true looking real
good
they're all looking good you know what's
looking good pennsylvania's looking good
pennsylvania
that great red wave is going to be very
beautiful to watch we're looking good
and if we win pennsylvania it's over
it's over not true
if he loses i think it's over if he wins
not so much i have the democrats and
they play dirty
you have the rhinos the rhinos are not
good people
you got them all but uh we're here and
you have your second amendment you have
your tax cuts
you have your regulations thanks to
trump you have your second amendment
you're fracking you have your fracking
imagine cheering for practice for a year
there will be no fracking
there will be no i tell you there will
be no frac it comes to pennsylvania
listen we have a million jobs for
fracking
we like two dollar gasoline you know
it's nice isn't it
we got a lot of things in front well in
that case let me just change mine
and he never even gets asked about it by
the fake news can you believe it
with your support we will continue to
bring back your jobs cut your taxes
cut your regulations and ensure more
products are proudly stamped
with that beautiful term made in the usa
i actually think at this point it is
word for word
the same speech every day with the town
names
changed to line up with the state he's
in i think it's literally the same
speech now
a man got on television yesterday said
this is probably the greatest
economic day in the history of our
country and the papers barely
even put it in it's called suppression
suppression joe biden will shut down
your economy
well you're already shut down in
pennsylvania hey governor you got to
open up
you got to open up the state governor
got to open it up
he tells every governor that in every
state
and don't cheat on the ballots governor
don't cheat don't you
every democratic governor sorry are you
going to win the only way we can lose
this state and the numbers are in you
see what's going on right
somebody's going to play games and they
just get an extension what's the
extension all about
wouldn't you like to hear november 3rd
we win
we lose we win we lose whatever
now you have more time more time on
what's going on
that was a very disappointing opinion
but i've had many disappointing
opinions from judges many many
disappointing opinions from the supreme
court they talk about we control the
supreme court we don't control the
supreme court
that was a terrible decision joe biden
will shut down your economy
here we go wipe out your factories and
shut down your state
and electricity china raise your taxes
four trillion dollars the biggest tax
increase
the biggest tax increase in the history
of our country
and i gave you the biggest tax cut in
the history
he'll eliminate your private health care
180
million people have the best health care
they
work so hard the best negotiate with
many great companies and have the best
what
healthcare they want to knock it out
they want you to live on socialized
medicine i don't think you'll be too
happy
biden will end sunlight darling i have a
call don't go to the hospital room
you'll wait online for about four days
that'll be nice
and send your state into a deep and
catastrophic
depression and wait will the hospitals
be busy because no one has health care
or everyone has health care i don't even
understand the criticism it's an
election things can happen we're doing
great much better than anyone
understands
and they so they're starting to get very
depressed you talk
about it to pray they get having a hard
time
they're having a hard time with it but
you know what there's a headwind you
know what the headwind is
that there's a possibility of biden wins
you're gonna have a stock market
collapse the likes of which you've never
had
stocks do far better under democrats you
guys know that i'm sure about it
if we win if we win on tuesday
or thank you very much supreme court
shortly thereafter if we win
let me tell you if we win you're going
to see a stock market that's going to go
like a rocket ship
yeah it's looked great the last five
days hasn't 401k is your 401ks
thank you
boy this is a very
enthusiastic group isn't it
this doesn't seem like someone who's
going to come
in second do you agree
oh man did you see biden and obama
before
they make you think hong kong honk
honk and actually most of them are our
supporters
trying to cause a little havoc but
that's all
we don't want your god bond is vowed to
abolish the entire u.s
oil industry no more fracking no mining
no heating no clean coal no cooling
and gas prices going up at five six and
seven dollars a gallon so when you pull
in with your car
you say you know darling i think we're
gonna sell this uh beautiful
this beautiful suv you say to your
husband sir i want an electric vehicle
please
the gas is too expensive what what has
this guy biden done
and the bad part is that biden doesn't
have a glue
glue he's gonzo we all know it
they just don't want to say it biden's
planned
i don't think he likes me too much is it
economic death sentence
for this great commonwealth it's a death
sentence
you'll eradicate your economy kamala
harris you
hear of kamala you have to pronounce it
she makes bernie sanders look like a
strict
conservative do you know now bernie's a
conservative member compared to her
i mean how that choice was made and did
our great vice president
win that debate easily
not the debate i said that's a big win
mike is doing a great job the most
liberal senator
even sponsored the green new deal 100
trillion dollars
ooh terrible 100 trillion than 106
now they have it down to 6 trillion no
it's not 6 trillion
and by the way if it was you couldn't
afford it but you can't afford a hundred
a vote for biden harris is a vote to ban
and you know this ban fracking
ban mining close up your
individual plants i got plants all over
the place i grew up here they
they have plants all over when i say
grew up let me be exactly like
during college because they'll say he
misrepresented he said he grew up
he met you know biden represents right
this is my home
this is not his home they left they
abandoned you wasn't his fault he was
nine years old or something right not
his fault
but it's not like uh you know he's a big
pennsylvania guy no he's a delaware guy
and delaware's a good place in fact it's
really good he likes it so much he never
leaves he never
okay he made the mistake he came to
pennsylvania
three days ago because i was here i was
doing three of them right three in
pennsylvania
hey i'm devoting a lot of my percentage
of time to pennsylvania in all
seriousness
he's from new york why does he say
pennsylvania why doesn't he say
pennsylvania
i don't understand is that an accent is
it a is it a dialect he's from queens i
don't know
pennsylvania it's over let's do it
i felt very badly i felt guilty because
if you remember four years ago
we were at 98 percent of the vote if i
lost
every single vote you know there were x
number of votes left
if i lost every single vote every vote
every
take them all i still win they refuse to
call it
they refuse they wouldn't call it i said
wait a minute
they have to call it because i was at
98.99 i was at 98
it stood there like for an hour and a
half and i kept saying that'd be nice
pennsylvania that'd be nice they refused
and then they said donald trump has won
the state of wisconsin
and then they said donald trump has won
the state
of michigan and we won and then like
much
later they just refused to give you the
credit so let's turn it around on them
okay
they didn't treat you when you step back
and then you're like how is trump's
president of the united states it gets
weird when you actually remind yourself
how insane
i said i'll concede every vote i'll
concede every one and we win they
wouldn't do that right
but we want it and we want it pretty
easily you know i think we want it
pretty easily
and what i've done from the time we won
the concept of conceding votes like
even votes that were for him he'll give
to the other person like
you you can't do that people voted for
this comment it's
has been incredible you had the best
year you've ever had last year
and you're heading to the best year
you've ever had period
and it's going to be this coming year
has this speech started does anybody
know
but biden would completely destroy
pennsylvania vote for me as a vote
to remain energy independent do you
believe it we can say that
right did you ever think you were going
to hear those beautiful words we're
energy independent
our economy is now growing at the
fastest rate
ever recorded that was what was
announced yesterday
if you don't understand basic math you
would think that a very very brilliant
gentleman called me up not a nice man at
all in fact he's ruthless and vicious i
love that guy with a beard back there he
goes to a number of
thank you he's so distinguished
he's so distinguished i see him at so
many rallies i appreciate it
i think he's great he's going four more
years that is great
but you know what he got up and he said
very smart very successful guy he said
you know
this could be the biggest announcement
in 50 years
33.1 gdp
that's growth he said we're down eight
percent
last time it broke the record it's the
number one in history of the history of
our country
and probably the history of any country
if you want to know the truth but
it's not even true i mean none of this
is true this is crazy far greater than
people were anticipating anybody so what
happens is that
this is the biggest announcement but you
watch they won't give you any credit
they'll try not to mention it's true the
press is
playing it down so much just like for
different reasons
they refuse to talk they refuse to talk
about where's hunter
they refuse to talk oh here we go
corruption
in biden's family we've learned more
about the uh
fake news but you know this is not this
is no longer fake news this is now
corrupt news oh okay corruption
we've learned a lot but we had the
greatest number we've ever had
i thought i heard that from over there
see i don't participate in this because
look at all the cameras back there look
at them all
you know what they're going to do he's
trying to incite them
no i don't have to incite them they're
like intelligent people they know
they know that when you get thrown out
of the military and you have no job for
a long time and then your father becomes
vice president
and then you get a hundred and eighty
three thousand dollars right
a hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars to sit on a board
probably never went to a board meeting
and supposedly three million up front
and then
the mayor of moscow's wife gives you a
check for three and a half million and
then
and then you go in air force two
and you go to a very nice place known as
china
that should have never ever done what
they did they should have never done
we just signed a great trade deal and
the ink wasn't dry and the plague came
in they should have
they could have stopped it but they go
to china
father and son goes to china and he
walks out with one and a half
billion dollars to manage which is
millions of dollars a year
and then he goes to the big play there's
like one particular woman who won't
stop screaming 10 million a year this
guy didn't have a job
a year before goes to china we want 10
million a year for introductory in other
words he'll introduce
people to his father and then you see
his father the big guy
the big guy they call him he's not a big
guy
he's not a big guy boom
he's not a big guy go i don't know if
you guys noticed what just happened
two um african-american gentlemen walked
right behind trump
and then one got up on the rafters and
almost was going to take a position
right over trump's left shoulder which
is just by coincidence where you often
will find
black folks at trump rallies in a very
particular position
and then there seemed to be some kind of
a discussion and then the guy left
very very strange a slight slap you
don't have to close
and there goes the other guy that walked
by before see that he's inciting
violence
no no but when biden i thought it was a
terrible thing remember that he actually
like
i want to take him to the back of the
barn they didn't say anything if i said
that they'd say this is a terrible human
being right
it's all right you know what in the
meantime we have the white house right
we have the white house
we have the presidency we have fracking
we have energy
we have manufacturing that they totally
gave up remember
the typical spot well the the where they
often either put
uh folks who are minorities or sometimes
they just have a sign
saying like latinos for trump blacks for
trump who knows really
you know what what the race they'll put
them right here which is very very
noticeable but that's noticeably absent
at this event
maybe there was a miscommunication we
are creating the world's greatest
economic powerhouse we are going to be
more powerful than ever before
we had to stop we had it close we had we
saved
two million lives remember they you know
they don't want to ever talk about that
the model was 2.2 million that's what
they said yeah if you do nothing we
saved 2 million lives we closed it up
how would you like to be me i'm sitting
there we have the greatest economy in
the history of
this country in the history of the world
we were we were
doing so much better than china i was
throwing tariffs on them they were
paying us billion dollars
i gave 28 billion remember our
businesses pay the tariffs because they
were targeted by
china iowa and nebraska they'll remember
they'll remember i gave them 28 28
billion whether it be
farmers farmers and ranchers because
they were targeted by china because they
thought china thought they could use the
farmers
to get the deal that they want because i
said i'm not going to let you rip off
the united states you've done it long
enough
for years and years and i'm not just
talking about obama i'm talking about
other presidents too they allowed this
to happen
they allowed this to happen so we gave
our farmers 28 billion that's not bad
all from china i said please write a
letter say thank you very much
tuning out a recent gallup poll found
that 56
of americans say they are better off
today than they were four years ago
under think of that
and that's during we're rounding the
turn they hate when i say it
you know we're coming up with the
vaccines the therapeutics are incredible
here i
am i mean you know
i'm sure i would have been here without
the therapeutic because as you can see
i'm in perfect physical shape
and i'm extremely young so i'm young and
i'm a perfect physical specimen
powerful uh
no so i'm sure i could have beat it
without but something happened when i
took that sucker and i was gone
are you guys noticing there's one
particular woman who's been screaming
yelling things the entire time i guess
she must be near a crowd mic or
something i don't know it's weird
and i was campaigning like uh very short
off the other side
were they happy oh are they happy but
you know what
when you're president of the united
states you can't lock yourself into a
basement at the white house
gotta be president i meet people right i
can't lock myself into the basement and
they have a very good basement
i can't lock myself into a beautiful
bedroom and stay there for a year and a
half
the president of the united states is
locked in the most magnificent bedroom
on the third floor of the white house
because we have a pandemic and he uh
he's afraid to go out he's your
president no
no you got to go out and uh the doctor
came up to me great doctors one thing if
you're president you get good doctors
cool you get plenty of them too they got
more doctors but they came up sir you're
positive you just asked the positive i
said
doctor tell me something for what
sir you have the china plague
he didn't say that he said kovitzer
covet
you know it's got about 24 different
names most of them should start with the
word china because that's where it came
from
sir you've tested positive for what is
this a place in italy
sounds like an island in italy corona no
i don't
it's the china it's the china virus
that's what it is
but he said sir you just tested trump
covey 20.
for covid i said uh that's not great
wait a minute i got about four campaign
stops reportedly he actually panicked
and was up all night as he developed a
fever
wreaking havoc at the white house
and then our great first lady tested
positive
that's uh well at least those rumors
that we don't live together turned out
to be false
oh my god
she lives in a house someplace in
virginia
no no she lives with me and
she tested i said that's the only good
thing about her testing positive because
oh my god she's strong and knocked it
out but then they said you know that
they said
sir baron now baron's my 14 year old boy
who's very tall
and strong he's very strong is baron
even 14 do we know that
they said sir baron tested positive i
said huh
that's not good about 12 minutes later i
said how's baron doing
sir he shed it no problem he's fine
get back to school governor tell them
they have to give is that true did he
get baron's age wrong
is that true those young kids have been
baron
strong they have that very strong system
how is he uh he's just
imagine if baron was 18. was it bad
i don't think i had anything wrong there
that's one of those things right that's
the way it is they're young and they're
strong and their immune system is good
and they should go back to school
immediately
sleepy joe biden is a die-hard globalist
who spent the last 47 years
outsourcing your jobs opening your
borders and
sacrificing american blood and treasure
in
endless foreign wars in countries that
most of you
have never even heard of gun trees
they're all coming back the soldiers are
all coming back you know
so now 19 years to now
19 years and they were policemen they
policed areas but
it's uh ridiculous what they were doing
in this country
ridiculous biden is a washington vulture
who decimated your steel mills
annihilated your coal jobs clean coal
and supported every disastrous sell out
trade deal
for over the annihilate the reason why
i'm president
the real thing that bothered me more
than anything else i thought the wars
were crazy i thought
so much was bad but i i saw these trade
deals we were making with
countries both ally and foe and our
allies in many ways treated us worse
than the foe
we were treated horribly on trade and we
were treated horribly in the military
we had to pay for their military by the
way those days have ended very
substantially you know very very
substantial
biden was a cheerleader for nafta one of
the worst trade deals ever made maybe
the worst and
china's not like we have time to dive
into trade deals but
but nafta you know first of all
nafta and usmca um
structurally are not dramatically
different and of course the thing about
trade is
in the aggregate trade makes countries
richer
the larger the country the less it has
to gain from
trade but it also increases inequality
it's like you know
the idea that the problem is nafta per
se
you know that this is just nonsense
politics it's politics for people who
don't know a damn thing about anything
they're respected because they'll say
we'll pull the hell out of there we'll
pull out
and we won seven and a half billion
dollars all of a sudden we're winning
cases
i wish our supreme court treated us as
well frankly
that was some decision that was made
right let's not
let's not listen to the decision this
most important election in the history
of our country
november 3rd let's not wait november
third let's extend the date
let's give people more time to put in
ballots right
remember nobody has more time to put in
a ballot you have to fill out
and send your ballot by november third
but the idea is
if the postal service takes longer you
shouldn't be penalized as long as
you've voted by election day yesterday
we allow five points for cheating he
said in pennsylvania right
think of that one of the best pollsters
in the country the one who got it right
four years ago
he said trump's going to win
pennsylvania but you have to allow
five points for cheating you know you
have to allow five points for trump
cheating which is why we have to vote
that they gave no that's very
disappointing that was a very political
decision i have to say
they have not treated me well
pennsylvania lost half of its
manufacturing jobs
to these calamities of sleepy joe biden
do you like his new sunglasses you like
them
that's so you don't see the bad surgery
on the eyes here
oh my god no they're terrible those
totally they've got to get a little
if you're going to use that kind what
are they aviation right he's got to go
at least one or two sizes larger
aviators i don't like that i don't get
the silver deal going the whole deal
and he's very angry right you'd ever
notice you know what
the word is a different it's agitated
you know why he's agitated right
this is how you know the obama biden
rallies are getting
and you just hope he can keep it going
but it's not going to go much longer
that's why crazy nancy was trying to get
the 25th amendment so
if he ever got in we get him out and
then you have kamala
that should never be your first woman
kamala
bill can't say your name where's the way
i look at him in pennsylvania i don't
think we're gonna have to worry about it
too much okay
and florida and ohio and lots of others
north carolina is looking pretty good
did you see that and this is no longer
the fake suppression paul's
you know we had a thing wisconsin is
great and we won it last time
and we had a poll come out i'm up one
then i'm down one then i'm up one then
i'm even you know what this
crazy stuff but it's you know it's
within this area i think we're doing
much better than that
you know i think i think we're way ahead
you know i mean i don't know if i should
be happy or sad
people say i don't want to talk to you
about it then they go vote for trump you
know and we end up winning by a lot
but that's what happened last time they
thought i was going to lose because
everyone walking out the exit polls said
walk out
who you voting for none of your business
everybody that said none of your
business they were trump voters
how convenient remember at five o'clock
in the afternoon they said
trump lost well they forgot to say
you know they had the largest numbers of
it's called something else but i'm
trying to be nice because there's so
many young people here
it's not none of your business is a much
better word it's too worse
that they say but all those votes were
votes for me
so they don't count them so they said oh
it looks like it's going to be a rough
time for trump
and they were happy as hell and then the
votes came in
it was the boots came a little evening
for a lot of anchors that were crying
i don't know how this could have
happened yes i'm an impartial anchor
i'm an impartial actor how did this
happen the tears before
and everything that biden twisted his
knife into the backs of pennsylvania
workers
while biden was giving china your jobs
his family was raking in
millions of dollars from china millions
and millions of dollars
if biden wins china wins if biden wins
china will own the us
just remember that and with me it went
just the opposite
i will tell you one thing i could name
many countries that would like me to
lose you know they said that
uh germany that in germany and i have a
heritage
with germany i mean they should like me
but they like obama much better than
they should be
there's no way they can like me i said
pay up they don't pay their
they're delinquent in nato they owe us
billions and billions of dollars obama
never said pay up
i said you got to pay up otherwise we
have to take our troops out
and then i hear that they like him
better well they should you know what if
they ever liked me better
i'm not doing my job wait so is is he
glad they don't like him or he's upset
they don't like him i can't tell
we're gonna have winning like you've
never seen before in 2016 pennsylvania
voted
to fire this corrupt political
establishment and you elected an
outsider as president who is finally
putting
america first is that okay pennsylvania
and you don't have to take my word for
it
because on biden's record of economic
treachery
and i only do this for places i like a
lot
oh no is he doing the video they're
gonna get it started
put it on the website would there be any
place for fossil fuels
all right guys on that note it's gonna
it's gonna do it for me we've had
we've seen kamala harris we've seen
barack obama we've seen joe biden we've
now seen donald trump and the maga cult
this will continue all day uh i will
check back in with everybody tomorrow
but i think you mostly have a sense of
the direction today is going trump
running 90 minutes behind to rant
incoherently
like a guy yelling at clouds um so we've
got just three days left everybody
please vote please please vote
thank you so much for your support of
the streams and i will be back it's
it's gonna be so soon it'll be like the
stream never even ended
um but i'll i'll talk to you all y'all
as some would say
very very soon